c'est une commune de plus de 31 mille
huit cents habitants plaisir se situe à
la porte de la plaine de versailles
cinq listes s'opposent pour les
élections municipales de 2020 elle a
siégé au conseil municipal au sein de
l'opposition durant ce dernier mandat
annie joël priou hasseni porte la liste
où tafer pur plaisir dans le cadre de ce
scrutin une candidature soutenue par le
parti socialiste et europe écologie les
verts écologie et social solidarité ça
va bien ensemble puisque ça crée du lien
social et nous on veut recréer des liens
entre les quartiers parce que la
configuration de plaisir effectivement
les fêtes de telle manière qu'il ya
beaucoup de séparation soutenu par le
rassemblement national jean louis met
les mène la liste rassemblement pur
plaisir
conseiller en formation et bénévole dans
plusieurs associations il porte un
projet autour de plusieurs priorités la
sécurité l'offre de soins médicaux sur
la commune et le cadre de vie la
conservation des espaces verts le côté
médical avec une offre suffisante
un parking d'ailleurs sur cette gare la
gare plaisir grignon la rénovation du
vélib ou doit comporter un volet
sécurité maire de plaisir depuis 2012
joséphine coleman bergé souhaite briguer
un nouveau mandat
avec une équipe renouvelée elle se
présente devant les plaisirs oit dans la
liste baptisée plaisir avance elle
souhaite poursuivre les projets
enclenchés tout en engageant de
nouvelles actions on a enclenché toute
une série de grands projets structurants
comme par exemple le centre bourg qui
n'est pas anodin également
l'éco-quartier du vélib ou également la
zone high-tech au niveau de 52 et de la
zone de ste apolline lille siège au sein
de l'opposition municipale depuis 2012
djamel niati conduit la liste à gauche
toute une campagne soutenue par la
france insoumise le parti communiste
français génération point s et le parti
de gauche
un programme basé sur l'égalité et
l'émancipation citoyenne et l'écologie
l'émancipation des gens c'est on part du
principe que les gens sont à même de
pouvoir décider pour eux-mêmes
vous parlez de démocratie locale c'est
donner aux gens la possibilité de
s'émanciper c'est quoi c'est leur ouvrir
véritablement la vie la vie publique la
vie publique la vie politique de notre
de notre cité il a rejoint les rangs de
l'opposition en octobre 2019 sur fond de
désaccord avec la majorité en place
patrick jr et candidats pour ces
élections municipales une équipe
composée d'anciens membres de la
majorité de 2014
elle forme la liste plaisir notre ville
notre avenir
avons travaillé depuis de nombreux mois
maintenant avec les plaisirs oit pour
train pour transcrire tous ses besoins
tout ses priorités sur un programme sur
lequel nous nous engageons que nous
saurons mettre en oeuvre y compris pour
le retour des médecins dans la ville
pour davantage de bus et de navettes
interquartiers pour plus de justice et
plus de sécurité